Life's like a galaxy
floating amongst the sea of stars.
Black holes try to reverse your course,
You won't let them stop you anyhow.
Don't be afraid to gather your voice.
Don't be nervous
because in this society,
we won't hesitate to look away.
Shield of a magnifying glass
so all they see is half an image
Oh, take cover,
run down these stairs,
and run as fast as you can.
Run as fast as you can.
Because it's a journey, just you and me.
Pack your bags and arrividerci.
Don't let nobody tell you otherwise.
Wait until they see
the world through your eyes.
Painting pictures through your lenses
nobody is understanding.
And from your thoughts
out pours a story
one would have to learn to read.
But don't be easily swayed
because your brilliance is seldom seen.
It's your self-fulfilled prophecy.
It's not easy
trapped in a personal mythology.
If I could look through the glass,
would I ask if I could see what they see?
But it's a journey, just you and me.
Pack your bags and arrividerci.
Don't let nobody tell you otherwise.
Wait until they see
the world through your eyes.
Thank you so much.
When I was four years old,
my dad taught me
the Taos Pueblo hoop dance,
a traditional dance born hundreds
of years ago in Southwestern USA.
A series of hoops are constructed
out of willow wood
and they're used to create formations
of the natural world,
showing the many beauties of life.
In the dance, you're circling
in a constant spin,
mimicking the movement
of the sun and the passage of time.
Watching this dance was magic to me.
Like with a time capsule,
I was taking a look through
a cultural window to the past.
I felt a deeper connection to how my
ancestors looked at the world around them.
And since then, I've always been obsessed
with time capsules.
They come in many forms,
but the common thread
is that they hold a portal to a memory,
and they hold the important power
of keeping stories alive.
As a filmmaker and composer,
it's been my journey to find my voice,
reclaim the stories of my heritage
and the past,
and infuse them together
into music,
film,
and virtual reality
time capsules to share.
But first, I want to share a bit
about how I grew up.
In Southern California, I was raised
in a multi-generational home,
meaning I lived under the same roof
as my parents, aunts,
uncles, and grandparents.
On my mother's side,
she's Dutch Indonesian and Chinese
with immigrant parents,
and my father is Ojibwe
and an enrolled tribal member
of the prairie band Potawatomi tribe
in Northeastern Kansas.
So one weekend, I'd be learning
how to fold dumplings
and the next weekend, I'd be powwow
dancing traditional style
immersed in the powerful heartbeats
of drums and singers.
So being surrounded by so many cultures
was the norm for me,
but it was a really confusing experience.
It was hard for me to find my own voice
because I never felt I was ever enough.
I was never Chinese enough,
never Dutch Indonesian
or Native enough,
and because I never felt like I was a part
of any singular community,
I sought to learn the stories
behind my heritage
and connect them together
to rediscover my own.
And the first medium
I felt gave me a voice was music.
With layers of sounds
and multiple instruments,
I could create soundscapes and worlds
that were much bigger than my own.
And this right here is actually the setup
that I have in my room.
This instrument here is one
of my favorites to play.
It's the Chinese Guzheng Zither,
and I learned how to play it
from online tutorials,
and another thing I learned
was that while the hoop dance
is hundreds of years old,
the Chinese Guzheng Zither
has over 2,000 years of history.
And I noticed an interesting connection.
The Zither is tuned
to the pentatonic scale,
which is a scale found so universally
within the world,
and I noticed that native folk songs
also carry with it the pentatonic scale.
And in both Chinese and Native Folk,
I sense the sound of yearning
and longing for the past
and this the sound that deeply inspires
the music I create today.
And at the time, I wondered if I could
make this feeling
of immersion even more powerful
by layering images and visuals
over the music.
So I went back to online tutorials
to learn editing software,
and went to community college
to save money
and created films.
After a couple years of experimenting,
I was 17 and I had something
that I wanted to tell and preserve,
and it started with a question.
What happens when a story is forgotten?
I lead with this in my latest
documentary film Smoke that Travels,
which invites you into a world
of song and dance as I explore my fear
that a part of my heritage
will be forgotten in time.
As of right now, there are so many
Indigenous languages dying
due to historically forced assimilation.
From the late 1800s to the early 1970s,
Natives were forced into boarding schools
where they were violently punished
if they practiced traditional ways
or spoke their native language,
most of which were orally passed down.
Right now, there are 567 federally
recognised tribes in the United States
when there used to be countless more.
In my father's words, being Native
is not about the braids
or the feathers and the bead work.
Being Native is all about how we center
ourselves in the world as human beings.
After traveling with this film
for over a year,
I met Indigenous people
from around the world,
from the Ainu of Japan
and the Sami of Scandanavia
and many more who all were dealing
with this exact same struggle,
to preserve their language and culture.
And I want to tell a quick story.
Around that same time,
I finished my first-ever
tiny experiment with rotoscoping
an animation technique.
I traced over 112 frames from a video
of a beautiful, fancy shawl dancer
named Danielle Bear,
and this is how it looked.
So I posted this online, very tiny video,
not expecting anything,
just wanting to share it
with my friends and family.
And the next morning, unexpectedly,
I woke up to hundreds and thousands
of views and comments saying
"Oh man, I want to bring my shawl
back out and go back to the powwow,"
or, "Oh, I miss dancing,
I want to get back out there again."
And the most striking comment to me
was someone who said,
"I've never seen a fancy shawl dancer
animated before, ever."
And prior to this,
it never even occurred to me
that there aren't many traditional style
dancers in animated form.
They just don't exist.
And at this moment, I not only
realized the power storytelling has
to connect all of us as human beings,
but the responsibility that comes
with this power.
It becomes incredibly dangerous
when our stories are rewritten or ignored
because when we are denied identity,
we become invisible.
And this concept is so important to me
with new rising mediums,
like virtual reality.
In a medium so powerful where you could
surround yourself
and step into a new world
and immerse yourself
into these new perspectives,
it's so important that we have
our identities and stories
existing within them
in the foundational era right now.
And it's also important
for the creators themselves
to be empowered to make these experiences
just for the joy of storytelling.
Right now, I'm exploring
a young VR video game programmer's
cyberpunk musical adventure
set in Tokyo, Japan.
And I'm dreaming up this world
in virtual reality room-scale,
a diary filled with a treasure trove
of objects,
from a favorite toy
to an old family trinket,
3-D scanned in from the real world,
and when you pick up that object
you could hear the very story
behind it,
just like a time capsule,
again, like a window to the past.
And I'm more fascinated with creating
alternative realities
that let us draw parallels to our own,
rather than recreating the real world.
Because all around us here,
we're all mixed,
mixed backgrounds, mixed cultures,
different hometowns,
and whether we know it or not,
whether we're aware of it or not,
we have so many stories and events
in our lives and our histories
that make up who we are today.
And we're all storytellers.
Perhaps reclaiming our narratives
and just listening to each other's
can create a portal
that can transcend time itself.